[Music]
it's amazing that this page and sea
portrays his personality and
several moments of his life he likes
to mark he was not a child thinking about
football only inter tite with a court I'll
know about the rock that's all the
tattoo he made of  boy in the favela portrays
his life what he went through
the dreams he wanted where he
was going to get
thank god my gift to achieve much
more than i wanted i imagined of
course and now it wants to stop for me fashion is to
continue
[Music  ]
neymar's written tattoo boldness and
joy that neymar
carries with him for a long time in football in the person
he is identical to the one used in the place if you
could be making some moment that
makes a difference
I don't think these things are just
main inep a  life seriously but not
so much this can be just one so
enjoy every moment who you love
with who you feel even so
was neymar that this guide the sun that
certainly or was a very
remarkable moment in the life of  le né,
several names of the 12 teams are
remarkable in her for the first title at the
moment
he is not just a football player before
he became a person much more than
that a special person of his own a lot of
people united a hero for many people
that the future of neymar  guard where a lot of
good things still seem to be the champion
[Applause
] big rio missed another penalty and
we can go very far
is what the police imagine